let's get started if we yeah
one two
[Applause]
ginger ale is crazy and I stumbled
across a show called embarrassing bodies
I saw is all about penises and there
were tops of penises that had problems
these people actually decided to go on
the show yep and showcase their
embarrassing can I show you something
I'm really embarrassed about
did you watch Downton before no my wife
is an addict and by addict I mean like a
crack addict and it's like a problem we
were supposed to start the show together
and I came to bed one night and she said
I've just watched six of them and she
was like no and so she's done the whole
thing and and I'm and I'm on my own
because I love you but I'm gonna have to
find time somehow to do that David is
here but in certain parts of the
audience and the audience at home there
might be some disappointment because
people were perhaps hoping that they
would be seeing Matt Damon and his
ponytail it's quite the sensation this
summer in ponytails ponytail when did it
go well I had it you know I did a movie
in China and in it and so I was there
for about five months with that with
that thing and then we did a press
conference at the very end
no it was I you know it was really it
was hair extensions oh it wasn't real no
it took there are seven hundred hair
extensions it was a full day to put them
in they flew somebody a wonderful woman
from here all the way to Beijing to do
to do it and we did it like on a Sunday
it took us the entire day so and then I
had to manage that here I never knew I
have a whole new appreciation for my
wife and daughter it's very hard to do
because Matt Damon's ponytail it ended
up with its own Twitter account you know
that okay but also people you know
people really appreciated that ponytail
on Twitter I don't know if you found
some of the tweets that people so mmm
Matt Damon with a man bun sad lady boner
they they get worse you think you were
basically understanding of the world
then you see Matt Damon's ponytail and
nothing makes sense this one this one's
quite extreme Matt Damon it's a ponytail
never would sit at our table I think my
ovaries might explode so never put it in
a talk
don't do that who knows what this last
one means Matt Damon I will use your
ponytail to steer while you dine upon my
lady sandwich
[Applause]
she's really thought it through she's
the one image they've released so far of
the new Bourne film it's got a name by
the way I don't think it's got a name
yet I know that cleanup in Aisle seven I
know but I said only I was allowed to
work at a deep red thanks for sending
the memo to everybody but me yes all
doesn't it yeah it's weird I've never
seen this color and now I see it on
three minute we have a go at Matt night
and in movie time it's even more because
the the third one and the second one are
supposed to dovetail like the third ax
take place at the same time so
technically James Bourne has a James
Bourne and Jason bond is fine
[Applause]
now Matt Damon have you ever been in a
musical yeah
is this a musical no but I'm playing
Humpty Dumpty in that book but look at
the dedication seriously
that was I was full-on I I mean I was I
don't know 14 or whatever but I knew
this is what I wanted to do and I
thought it took that kind of
determination is this when you cool with
benefit yes yeah and that's when your
connection started was back then yeah
yeah and this is when you you would have
the lunches these acting lunch business
lunches yeah we call them business
lunches and you were like 14 yes I was
16 and he was 14 and and we would and we
would there were two cafeterias we went
to a very big high school there were
3,000 kids and there was the main
cafeteria and then what they called the
media cafeteria which was a small
cafeteria and we would meet at the media
cafeteria for a business lunch and we
get our cheeseburgers and we'd sit down
and we wouldn't have anything to talk
about we did and where you from Rebecca
New Zealand
you surprised me so this is a situation
where we're allowed to if one of us
pulls this lever she flips yeah okay
like the Milgram
[Applause]
hi ru hi I just like to say that I think
Matt Damon is really amazing in the
fourth form this is the best time I've
ever had on a talk show
[Applause]
[Music]